не скоєно поза народними депутатами
учасники тіла засідання я думаю що
шкір политих знай та акція горнова
вириті протягну на спідниці дну інвесту вати
у людський капітал ми не навіть приймаєш
юнака ряд відсотки на нього малюка
говорити про сам робот ідеї та процес
свічусь фінансово не складаємо його почту
вдавиться будь ласка тут хлопець не цифри
і вид сотках ВВП і абсолютні цифри ми
також змогли і ви маєте рацію ти пам'ятав крики
були пов'язані з процесом децентралізації
передачі професіонал технічні світіно
місця обласного значення за раз у нас у
регульована живлення управління
професіонал технічну у святу ми до
дав із субвенцію на 2 мільярди на
зуби казуальні середнього свити
інвестувати їм у святе вид соток ввп нації
річки та плану та cc 650 чистив їх
адже соткою в парі мене немає
ми новим роком 5,7
для нас душа увійшла його щоб ми могли
покраше ти інфраструктуру інфраструктуру
наших початкових закладів ios інвестиції
та рядів з 2016 у сімнадцятому роті
димий розум з органами місцевого самого
ряду ваня покришили мустанг затятих
shteel куб та і мушки не автобуси
обладнання природне ніж від них від особистих
кабінетів у перші з'явилася субвенція
на інклюзивному свиті дим та стимулі йому
щоб дітей суса би ви ми потребуватимемо і
включав і мовчання у випадкових початкових
закладок ти навіть важливого для
соціалізації порожнім напливу і наших
дітей
я прошу вже краще висоти у презентацію
якихось дряпати тому що я на мою
культу хто вистоє презентацій минулі
стати презентацію про g дощ і не висвітли
ви бачатою як цифра створених міс ми
так вже попит тили санпіни і для нас
перспектива 40 тис. дали у нарощуванні
месі а також з менше ти
бюрократичні процедури у вигляді крику
дошкільних початкових заслуг у приватній
владності і змішала і владності в
задній середні у світі ми продовжуємо
відкривати
упор не школи тому що ідея полях а це
до початкова школа я до найбільшого пекла
місця проживання дитинки
вид зі старших класів мати на вч
сну в нормальному bloodmoon їх кабінетах
з фа хува ми у 4 ми she але не народний
депутат і до вашого відома та поганого
стоїш що сьогодні шуму бізнес
десятикласники в Україні дітей 10 клас
у сільських територіях на 32
сотки 10 класних і навіюється у школах
дим менше 10 учень то тут у всій школі
о 1 в 4 нав чай ​​п'є з і ми предметом я
кому ж ніби я киса свити там у для ти
хто вікторії не роблю злили мохаммед так
у тюрмі ви комірник прогнати у там не
було важливим
у чорні листи пенсії викладати йому
діставшись предмету до цього я хочу тем
хто просто сліпа повторі яга слабкий рот і
оптимізації по мені те ти що за
оптимізацію коштувати якісь про святі дітей
нас вороги соціальні стандарти для у
світлонія
все було дуже важливо ви сну і визнає я
вже до побачилася що ми раз пачино йому
реформу середні sweet іншого українська
школа їй і вид цирку я закон про
святі кай прийнятої першому че-то не
готується до тремтіння і від прийнятої
концепції політично пропозиція уряду
можна вступати в реформу кількох інвіз
одразу страва річки буде такою вже раб цієї
сури форму ми підняли на 52 сотки в
зарплату в чотири милі перу засунула їх
під потери внести ціна 2 тарифні
розряди і так сам встиг шоу rss
тусуватися з усіх педа логічних
супротивники
професії та технічного кольору позики та
муся про новий стандарт за рік
врученням прем'єр-міністра праці i'm an
attempt про розрубає і бішкек чи не може
його стиль для перетворення робота доп
самий нам будуть потрібні зміни до
законодавства для тіла щоб створи ти
розумом і для дуального на вч вони уникнення
баз практики київ нас є професій на
технічніше узбеки ви шоу свято у вищого
святитель займаємося стандартами та
дорослі стипендією ок ви знаєте тут я
всі кільки з не показано кіно на повторі
usa шлюбом часу
проти що для нас уже увійшла його ми
брати своєму зараза над новим і
механізмом і фінансово не ваючі свята і
представимо uuid по видний законопроект про
парламенті
для нас дуже важливо під'їзду ти
стандарти вищого sweet з-під риб та
ринку брати не приходу ще й проблема в
мэн на цю статтю моєму кішки на
комунальні посол та овочі освітлення наука
від znau яку я стрибу наношу на ранок
баруха 35 нам потреба при я не і
парламенту тому що хоча ми поспішав і
фінансова наука укорінення злим роком
на 1 мільярд гривень cc рахунок дуже низько
цифра 500 як ВВП і не вигляд побачиш
закону бо я був потішний щоб ми малий
пак і дискусій на я
киркою пропаду ще не зарплат суддям
конституційного суду, щоб ми говорили
так вже про наших на кофті великих нам
треба в крим а ти тут і розвивати нашу
ну наукову структуру і здохну логічно на
нових засадах сам цьому ми зараз
пригнувшись до
програми горизонт 2020 ми вже забрав
інакше наук вівці у проекти в кивнув і
майже 12 у мільйоні в євро
олаф cct нема стати але без наших так вже
інвестицій ми будемо працювати з
парламентом ті уроку так вже над innovate
сильним закону дасть вам вигляд побити не
проекти готуватися за раз уряду дякую за
увагу